thank you
all right there's no other way
yeah
[Music]
foreign
imagine an underground world made of
concrete and steel stairways and tunnels
just enough light to see the signs on
the walls
Suppose there were people who lived down
here all their lives and were never
allowed to visit the surface and that
these people were told from the time
they were born that this world is all
that exists
wouldn't they believe what they're told
to believe when they try to live like
it's true
suddenly a Madman stumbles down the
stairs and says to the people living
here don't you realize that you're
underground don't you know that there's
an amazing world right up those stairs
and that a tomb no matter how spacious
is still a tune
but the people laugh at the man they say
we understand our world just fine
without all your rambling about another
go back to your flying spaghetti World
fool
where the enlightened ones down here
and in rejecting the world above they
sink a little deeper into the world
below
when I was five years old I had a dog
named Goliath
one day my mother received a phone call
she turned to me it was tears in her
eyes and informed me that Goliath had
been run over by a bus
I looked at her and thought to myself
so what it's just a dog
but my mother was sad and I couldn't
figure out why
I soon noticed that other people got sad
when something died seemed really weird
to me crying isn't going to change the
fact that it's dead so why are you
crying I also noticed that people didn't
share my amazing insights into the
nature of reality
remember sitting beside a lake when I
was eight years old watching ants March
in perfect formation
and it suddenly became entirely clear to
me that ants ruled the world and had
only tricked us human beings into
thinking that we were in charge
do you have any idea how powerful and
Brilliant they must be if they've
managed to deceive
the entire human population
a few years later I figured out that
pets actually controlled the planet
whenever a cat or a dog would look me in
the eyes I would think that it was
communicating with me silently bragging
that was much more intelligent that
humans were
so part of my youth who spent talking to
animals telling them
I know what's going on here I'm on to
you
but I grew out of that sort of silliness
by the time I was in 10th Grade I was
convinced that I controlled the weather
I didn't know how I control the weather
I just knew that I did it would start
raining and I would think okay how did I
do that
I also had the ability to control time
but I didn't know how to use this
ability yet
[Music]
summer my best friend from elementary
school died Jimmy had always talked
about going parasailing he finally got
the chance and his harness broke he
plummeted to his death
when I heard about it after knocking on
his door I had the same reaction I'd had
when my dog Goliath died namely so what
but this time was different it seemed
like I should be bothered by Jimmy dying
so I started wondering if something
might be wrong with me
after pondering this for several months
I realized why I was different I had
evolved to a higher stage of humanity
these sad little emotions the rest of
you have they're like vestigial Tales
left over from more primitive life forms
but Humanity 2.0 had arrived and you
earlier models were now obsolete
okay
following year
I had a life-changing experience I was
running from the police in the middle of
the night and they had me surrounded on
three sides the fourth side was the
Monongahela River so I jumped in and
swam across and started working my way
through the trees on the other side
I eventually emerged from a patch of
woods and I found myself in someone's
backyard
in front of me was a beautiful garden
I started to walk around the garden but
then I stopped to philosophize I thought
I don't care about the people in that
house
so why am I going out of my way to avoid
stepping on their vegetables why am I
being so courteous
because I've been brainwashed that's why
I've been breaking the law for years and
yet Society had been manipulating my
behavior all along greatness had been
polluted by mediocrity
as I stunt my way through that Garden I
had an incredible Rush of Freedom the
world has all of us on a leash a leash
made of rules do this don't do that but
it's a leash that slips right off as
soon as we recognize that we don't have
to do anything anyone tells us to do
of course
if you really want to break free from
your handlers
seems like you have to do the opposite
of what you've been told
going down
started studying bomb building when I
was 18. nothing fancy yet I got a copy
of the Anarchist Cookbook I learned to
make pipe bombs I learned to put
together a homemade grenade launcher I
bought a book on disguises so I wouldn't
be recognized but it all felt a bit
amateurish so I decided to become a
chemistry major in college where I could
learn to build something a little more
sophisticated
but my plans of becoming a bomber had to
be put on hold because
there are more important things in life
anyone can blow up a bunch of random
people you don't know them
if you're
sick of Life dangling at the end of
society's puppet strings
The Killing has to start much closer to
home
my dad was the only relative I had
within a few hundred miles so he
obviously needed to die and I had a ball
peen hammer that would do the trick
interestingly some of my amazing
insights into the nature of reality
actually slowed me down
my dad was sitting beside me on the
couch and I was about to beat him to
death I had the hammer under a cushion
but I suddenly realized that he was
reading my mind and not just him
everyone in the world was reading my
mind I was part of an experiment and
billions of people were in on it
they were all waiting to see what I
would do and as soon as I uh attacked my
dad the walls would rise up The
Observers would rush in and the
experiment would be over
since my dad is reading my mind I'm
channeling my thoughts to him as we sit
there he's watching television and I'm
thinking
look at me while you're reading my mind
look at me right now I'm going to bust
your head open
finally I channel to him I think I'm
stupid I'm not falling for this and then
I got up and walked out
but it wasn't over
after a while my senses returned to me
and I walked into my dad's bedroom at
about two o'clock in the morning
Thanksgiving Day
I stood over him with the hammer and I
tried to think of one wrong thing he'd
ever done to me
nothing came to mind
so I drew back my arm and came down on
him with all 230 pounds
I didn't know how fast blood could come
out of someone's head
kept hitting him until I was sure he was
dead and I walked outside and drove away
there was no rush of Freedom this time
I didn't feel anything anymore
did I mention that I was an atheist
I understand that most of you atheists
out there live perfectly normal lives
but I can never understand why you would
want to think about it we've got this
massive universe and over here is a tiny
little crumb of a galaxy I don't want to
the spiral arms of this galaxy is a
thoroughly unremarkable ball of hot gas
circling this ball of hot gas is a
pathetic Speck of cosmic dust we call
Earth and crawling all over the Earth
are these feeble selfish
self-destructive lumps of cells
constantly diluting themselves into
thinking that what they do is so
important
but the universe couldn't conceivably
care less whether you love your neighbor
as yourself or torture him to death for
fun so you might as well do whatever you
feel like doing with a little bit of
time you've got and what are my atheist
friends going to do with your 80 years
or so
let me guess you're going to go to
school for a while then get a job work
for a few decades maybe pick up a family
along the way
then retire and die of old age or some
illness
original
free thinkers huh believe it or not some
people don't want to live like cattle
some people don't want to follow this
pattern that we're all expected to
mindlessly follow some would rather bash
a man's head in or shoot up a theater or
walk down their school hallway stabbing
people and why shouldn't they because
it's wrong
it says who your grandma
or should they try not to hurt people
because people have intrinsic value
here I thought that human beings are
nothing but machines for propagating DNA
most people don't want to kill in
Slaughter but for those who do our
civilization is rapidly destroying any
significant reason they might have for
resisting the urge to kill and Slaughter
young people are lining up to dance to
the music of their DNA all you can do
now is hope that they get tackled when
they stop to reload or that they make
some huge blunder when their bloodbath
begins
I made a huge blunder when my bloodbath
began I underestimated the amount of
damage a human head could endure crushed
skulls can apparently be pieced Back
Together by doctors my dad had brain
damage but
he survived the attack I was taken to a
mental hospital and later to jail
is a place to sit back and reflect on
the things you've done you've got plenty
of time to sit back and think
why did I get caught what steps can I
take to avoid getting caught next time
and without all of the empty
repetitive tasks that ordinarily keep
you mentally sedated you've got plenty
of time to
to figure out what's most important to
you foreign
the most important thing to me was not
being a slave to people for whom I had
nothing but contempt
but people had controlled me in various
ways throughout my life and this meant
that they would need to be taught a
lesson
I had a list of people going back to
kindergarten who were going to be
brutally murdered
but doubts
occasionally crept in
I would ask myself
is there a point to any of this
nothing really matters so what
difference does it make whether I do
everything I've been planning or I do
nothing at all
there's no blue ribbon for making the
right decision here because there is no
right
but when I would start to think that
life off the leash was just as
meaningless as life on the leash I'd
start to lose my mind
I was able to hold things together to
some extent
mentally because I had something to do
but if what I had to do was pointless
then holding things together was
pointless
so I was at an edge
and there's nowhere to go but over it
[Music]
life
as a way of giving us an alternative
at just the right moment
one of my hands one empty Kettle he
should be on his metal
just because I'm presuming that I could
be kind of human
If I Only Had a Heart
when I was in e-block in the jail
I met a Christian named Randy a guy who
had turned himself in for 21 felonies
Randy seemed like he was from another
world there'd be a fight in the dorm and
he wouldn't watch he uh he turned his
head away and pray for it to stop our
main source of entertainment and he's
praying against it
Christian's cracked me up
Randy was lying on his bunk reading his
Bible one night and I walked up to him
and said
do you know why you're reading the Bible
you're reading the Bible because you
were born in the United States if you've
been born anywhere else you believe in
something else if you've been born in
China you'll be a Buddhist if you've
been born in India you'll be a Hindu if
you've been born in Saudi Arabia you'll
be a Muslim because people like you
believe whatever you're told to believe
I've since heard other atheists say the
same thing and almost exactly the same
words so I take it that this is a common
atheist view of Christians which is
hilarious in his level of hypocrisy I
believe that the Universe exploded out
of nowhere for no reason and that life
formed on its own and that Consciousness
was a natural product of particle
interactions in our brains and that
moral values were nothing but societal
indoctrination and Jesus followers made
up the story about him rising from the
dead because they wanted his message to
spread I believed all of this without
anything remotely resembling a careful
investigation of the evidence which
means I believed a lot of what I'd been
told but I'm pointing a finger at the
Christian
why
because it's much easier to make fun of
someone else than to do the difficult
work of putting together a coherent
well-grounded belief set
something interesting happens when I
made fun of Randy he fought back
lots of Christians will go into Retreat
mode if you start arguing with them they
don't want to cause a scene but Randy
sat up on his bunk and proceeded to
embarrass me about some of the things I
was saying
47 50th Street I was totally shocked
I don't know what was going on I'm the
smartest most advanced human being the
world has ever seen and night after
night when we are arguing
uh Randy was just taking me to a to a
school and he wasn't
smarter than me he didn't have any
special knowledge or degrees he he
wasn't a scientist or a philosopher he
just had an annoying habit of
questioning everything I would say and
when I would try to answer his questions
about what I was saying it would become
clear to him
and to me that many of my beliefs when
put into words sounded really really
stupid things that made perfect sense
when unquestioned made no sense at all
when questioned
I became so frustrated by our arguments
that I began looking for other ways to
defeat Randy I made fun of him for
getting molested when he was a child I
saw his uh his 12 year old sister in the
visiting room and I said some things
about her that I'm not going to repeat
here I keep messing with him until he
got upset and when he got upset I'd say
look at you getting angry of me
call yourself a Christian
oddly enough Randy and I became friends
we'd stay up all night playing cards
throwing a roll of toilet paper around
like it's a football and of course
arguing about the Bible
but I was still looking for ways to
defeat him at something so we got into
the world's first ever fasting battle it
wasn't a battle for him he wasn't trying
to outdo me at anything
but I was certainly trying to outdo him
Randy would fast for long periods of
time nothing but water
after a while I joined in
and whenever he would complete a fast
I'd start my own fast and then go a few
days longer than he did
for our first exchange Randy fasted one
week
I knew he wasn't eating because he gave
me all his meal trays
when he was finished I said all right
I'm going
10 days I had never gone a day without
food in my life
but I went 10 days straight just so I
would know that I had beaten the
Christian
we went back and forth with me always
going a few days longer than he did
eventually
he asked me he asked me uh hey how come
you always fast a little longer than I
do are we in some sort of competition
that I don't know about I said no I
hadn't even noticed just coincidence I
guess
Randy fasted 40 days
he went 32 days on nothing but water and
then he added liquids like Kool-Aid for
the rest
told me that Jesus had gone 40 days and
that's why he picked the number 40. I
said all right I'm going 42. and even
six weeks of nothing but water and rage
I was going to beat Randy and Jesus
on the 11th day of my fast
uh a guard came in and told me to pack
up my stuff I had passed out earlier and
hit my head on the way down the medical
staff knew my mental health history and
they thought I was trying to start
myself to death
I'm trying to beat the Christian they
think I'm trying to commit suicide
really really slowly
but they had seen that I'd lost enough
weight to realize that there was a
problem and a blood pressure monitor the
nurse put on my finger said that I was
dead so I had to pack up my books
philosophy and Science and the
Apologetics books Randy give me and head
to my new home
a cell with a camera where I could be
watched day and night
living the dream I lost about 80 pounds
from fasting I developed a horrible rash
all over my body it felt like felt like
poison ivy it's called shingles it's
caused by vitamin deficiency
was having blackouts I was getting
tunnel vision
the doctor at the jail said he was going
to tube feed me the
social worker was talking about having
me sent to my third mental hospital and
when I wasn't reading all I could think
about
was taking people out to the woods and
peeling their skin off
but I found renewed purpose in my lonely
cell with a library at my disposal and
nothing else to do I had a perfect
opportunity to prepare for an epic
showdown with Randy I could study the
Bible put together new arguments go back
to e-block and destroy the faith of my
friend
I asked the chaplain for some Bible
studies he gave me a series of studies
on the Gospel of John
with graded assignments
so here I am a rapidly deteriorating
atheist
sitting in a poorly lit cell doing my
Bible homework getting straight A's
I haven't eaten
in days
and I read about Jesus saying I'm the
bread of life he who comes to me will
never go hungry
I'm obsessed with liberating myself from
a society that has me trapped in a six
and a half by eight foot cell
and I read
the sun sets you free you'll be free
indeed
I'm wondering how long my body can take
what I'm doing to it before my heart
stops and I read I am the resurrection
and the life he who believes in me will
live even though he dies
kind of creepy when a book talks to you
but what do I know I used to think that
cats were talking to me
[Music]
lying on my back
day after day reflecting on life and
Theology and philosophy
three things
started to
destabilize my entire belief system
first
What's called the design argument
finally hit me I was looking at a wall
and how the bricks were arranged and I
thought to myself
you know
if someone told me that these bricks
went into this border
by some process that didn't involve
intelligence I'd smack him in the mouth
and yet I believe that life formed
without intelligence when the most basic
living cell is unimaginably more
complicated than some bricks stacked on
a wall
why did I blindly accept
the extraordinary claim that life
arose spontaneously from non-life
without demanding some very good
evidence
second I found out how Jesus Apostles
died
most of them went to their bloody desk
claiming that they had seen him risen
from the dead
my explanation for the origin of
Christianity had always been that
the apostles made up a story so that
they could spread his message but now my
explanation wasn't making sense if
you're willing to die for something you
have to believe it when a terrorist
blows himself up he's obviously sincere
so the disciples the apostles had to
believe what they were dying for but
this means that they were
they were convinced that they had seen
Jesus risen from the dead
now usually when someone is willing to
lay down their life for something it's
for an ideology that they got from
someone else and that ideology could be
true or false the disciples were dying
for something that they saw
what could have convinced so many
different people that they had all seen
a resurrected man
I could explain one witness by saying
he's crazy but
all of them
something was going on here and I had to
figure it out but I couldn't come up
with any explanation for why they had
that level of confidence other than they
actually saw him
third
be better than me now if you're not a
complete moral relativist or maybe one
of the new atheists it's probably
obvious to you that Jesus is better than
me but I wasn't the clearest thinker on
moral issues back then so uh getting my
mind around this was very difficult
here's the problem that emerged
I had two beliefs that just didn't go
together on the one hand I believe that
human beings are
lumps of cells meaningless lumps of
cells that everything we did was
pointless
at the same time I believe that I was
the best most important person in the
entire world
how is it possible to be the best most
important worthless lump of cells
if there were to be some sort of best
person that would require something like
you know a standard of good and that
would require something like God and
then someone like Jesus would be better
than me
so my beliefs were
breaking down at the foundational level
and once the foundations start crumbling
everything starts coming down I went
from believing that I was the best
person in the world to thinking that I
was the worst person in the world and In
a Moment of clarity it all just hit me
thinking
I'm a guy who
once
choked my friend until bloody foam came
out of his mouth I hit him with a shovel
because he disagreed with me I don't
even remember what it was about
I used to watch my mom's boyfriend beat
her and I wouldn't lift a finger to help
her
not because I was scared I was 200
pounds and I had a gun I could have
stopped it at any time I just didn't
care and I was proud of the fact
that I didn't care
I thought about what I'd done to my
family what I was doing to myself they
brought me food every single day and I
was starving to death because I wouldn't
eat it there were other starving people
in the world but at least they could
think straight I sat there thinking
about
torturing people my skin was turning
yellow
I was scratching myself bloody what
sense did it make to think that I'm the
best at anything
when I was thinking about that situation
I just thought you know it feels like
I've just been stomped relentlessly into
the ground and when I when I thought
that
I I started comparing it with a little
Hospital stay about a year and a half
earlier
I got a new fight with seven guys I'm
not saying that to be tough they want
that one they won that one I got one of
them he hit me with a gun and I hit him
with uh with these guns and then his six
friends got on me and got me on the
ground and then took turns Soccer
kicking me in the head but I was
comparing that to to the situation I was
in I was thinking
foreign
scratches on my neck I was dizzy walking
around I had my arm in a sling but I was
okay
fighting seven guys is a joke compared
to what I was going through in that cell
I feel like I've just been stomped into
the ground and when I thought that I
felt like I'd been stomped into the
ground
I had another flashback
one night I was walking home from a
friend's house and a storm hit there was
rain was so bad I could barely see
lightning was striking all over the
place and I looked up and mockingly said
oh is that supposed to scare me if you
want me to believe in you better come
down here and make me believe
I wasn't serious but given my
circumstances in the jail I had to start
wondering if God had taken it seriously
that normally wouldn't have been uh an
option I didn't I didn't think like that
but since my entire world view was
crumbling
I wasn't in a position to dismiss
alternatives
but there's a problem
[Music]
if there was a god involved in all of
this
if right and wrong weren't merely useful
fictions
I was in all kinds of trouble not just
for what I had done but for what I was
how is the worst person in the world
going to ever do the right thing there's
no there's no magic switch that I can
flip and oh now I care about other
people
so how was I going to do anything right
and then it hit me that there are two
possibilities either
I'm violent and selfish and uncaring and
that's just the way things are
or there's someone who can help people
like me
either I'm all messed up and that's that
I just had to live with that or there
was someone who could deal with this
sort of thing
and when you start thinking like that
I'd say you're about two inches away
from becoming a Christian because when
we ask ourselves who out of anyone ever
who had the ability to take
psychologically spiritually and morally
shattered people and give them new life
we get a list of one
you get a list of one there's one person
on the list he's the one who said
I am the door if anyone enters through
me he will be saved and will go in and
out and find pasture the thief comes
only to steal and kill and destroy I
came that they may have life and have it
abundantly
I didn't know if Jesus was
who he claimed to be
but I knew that it was Jesus or nothing
it was Jesus or nothing if anyone has
God's stamp of approval it's the guy who
rose from the dead
history is filled with dead options
Jesus is the last living option
so I bowed down
on my bunk not sure of much of anything
and I prayed
I didn't know how to pray but I prayed
and I said God
I don't know if I'm going to believe in
you tomorrow
but I believe in you right now
if you can do anything with me
you're welcome to it
and then I continued with a kind of
sinner's prayer that I had read in those
Bible studies
and when I sat up
from that prayer
the entire world looked different
like everything was a different color
for the first time in a lot of years
I didn't want to hurt anyone
when I had a strange sense
that I'd somehow known the truth all
along
God created the universe but we're
something special we're created in God's
image
but we reject God and in rejecting God
we strive to
twist and warp His Image which we bear
for years
I was willing to sacrifice everything
for a kind of Freedom just a freedom
from external control
to false freedom because we just end up
using it
to degrade and destroy ourselves
tarnishing the image of God so that we
won't be reminded of what we are and
what responsibilities we share
true freedom
is found
in not having
this inclination and desire
to turn against our creator
that's the true freedom
[Music]
after I prayed
I felt like I had been
fighting
not
figuratively fighting I mean physically
brawling my entire life and that I
finally had a chance
to sit down and rest
that rest never went away
[Music]
as Lewis put it
I believe in Christianity as I believe
that the sun is risen not only because I
see it but because by it I see
everything else
[Music]
lots of people and their testimonies
will share their stories of what
happened after they became a Christian
we could talk about that some other time
right now I just wanted to explain why
I'm a Christian and my reason for being
a Christian has never changed
I stand on the words of the one who rose
from the dead because there is no other
place to stand
and just to show you
that Jesus Christ is the same yesterday
and today and forever
I'll conclude my story with the words of
another Christian from nearly 2 000
years ago
the Apostle Paul
tried to annihilate Christianity before
he met Jesus on the road to Damascus
shortly before his death he wrote a
letter to his friend Timothy and said in
words that could be echoed by thousands
of other Christians over the centuries
I thank Christ Jesus our lord who has
given me strength that he considered me
faithful appointing me to his service
even though I was once a blasphemer and
a persecutor and a violent man I was
shown Mercy because I acted in ignorance
and unbelief the grace of our Lord was
poured out on me abundantly along with
the faith and love that are in Christ
Jesus
here is a trustworthy saying that
deserves full acceptance Christ Jesus
came into the world to save Sinners of
whom I am the worst but for that very
reason I was shown mercy so that in me
the worst of sinners Christ Jesus might
display his unlimited patience as an
example for those who would believe on
him and receive eternal life
now to the king Eternal Immortal
invisible the only God the honor and
Glory forever and ever
amen
[Music]
you ready for our interview